- You pushed the release of your album,
your new album to honor George Floyd.
How are you interpreting
this moment in our country?
'Cause you're of the younger generation
and you're very powerful
and I think we've all
been really impressed
with how the younger generation
is handling all of this.
How have you specifically
been handling it?
- Thank you, yes.
Well, the first couple of weeks,
when everything was happening
we were definitely just very sad
and I feel like, collectively,
in our community of our
black brothers and sisters,
it's like this collective
feeling of just trauma
when something like that happens
because for me, personally,
I think of my little
brother, we think of our dad.
That could have been them.
So, we just are trying to
do everything that we can
to continue to lift each
other up with our voices
and demand justice for what's right.
I mean, our color of our skin
should not be a death sentence.
People deserve to live a
beautiful and long life,
just like everyone else.
- Exactly, yeah.
- I mean,
it's crazy that's not a given.